merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse aux mises de l'action et les
comptes publics
un an et demi après l'avènement du
nouveau monde les français sont
désespérés exaspérés bien sûr vous
héritez d'un passif lourd mais 73%
d'entre eux ont le sentiment que leur
situation s'est dégradée et qu'ils sont
injustement pénalisés chez les retraités
ce chiffre atteint du jamais vu 94% et
ils se sont de surcroît méprisé traité
de gaulois réfractaires ou de fainéants
les classes populaires et moyennes sont
accablés par l'impôt au de la csg pour
les retraités hausse de la fiscalité
énergétique baisse des aides au logement
si bien que la france est championne du
monde des impôts et des taxes
ce matraquage n'est plus compris
d'autant qu'il est inefficace puisque la
dette publique continue de s'envoler
sans créer d'amélioration les
territoires sont abandonnés déserté par
les services publics et de santé les
commerces et les transports
et ensuite on explique qu'il nous faut
renoncer à la voiture on surtaxe
carburant ont parsèment les routes de
radars qui ont généré près de 2
milliards d'euros de recettes en 2017
vous êtes anglais financièrement les
collectivités à coups de réduction des
dotations faisant porter sur les mers la
responsabilité d'arbitrer des hausses de
fiscalité
vous êtes dur avec les français la voilà
la réalité
votre politique est injuste et illisible
pire déconsidère aux yeux des gens la
parole politique elle même la france qui
travaille souffrent elles peinent à
boucler les fins de mois elle peine à
payer la cantine scolaire des enfants
elles peinent à se nourrir correctement
à se loger dans le parc social et elle
peine à affronter les accidents de la
vie depuis ce week-end
cette phrase est sur toutes les lèvres
les élites parle de fin du monde quand
nous on parle de la fin du mois ma
question sera simple monsieur le
ministre
quand votre gouvernement va-t-il enfin
passer d'une idéologie à la réalité
allez vous enfin entendre la souffrance
qui expérimentent et français y compris
ceux qui vous ont fait confiance et qui
ne croient plus en rien je vous remercie
on vous répondra la parole et à monsieur
le ministre l'action à des comptes
publics monsieur gérald darmanin vous
avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice un sujet grave et important
que vous évoquez et finalement c'est la
question de la réussite du quinquennat
du président de la république à la suite
il faut bien le dire parce que nous
souhaitons tous sans doute que la france
réussisse
durant ces cinq ans je n'en ai
strictement aucun doute vis-à-vis d'un
peuple qui souffre et qui bien sûr vous
l'avez dit connais trop de taxes et
connais trop de dépenses publiques et
koné par ailleurs trop de dettes à vous
avec moi vous l'avez dit et ce n'est pas
qu'à passif récent que de nombreux
gouvernements depuis 40 ans c'est à dire
permettez moi de vous le dire avant la
naissance du président de la république
lui-même depuis 40 ans
depuis 40 ans la france sous diverses
majorité pour des raisons très
différentes à présenter des projets en
déséquilibre madame la sénatrice
permettez moi de vous dire que vous
m'appelez et vous appelez le
gouvernement la cohérence c'est à dire
de baisser les impôts
j'y suis très favorable et pour cela il
faut baisser la dépense publique
j'y suis très favorable d'ailleurs je
m'enorgueillis sous l'autorité du
premier ministre de présenter un projet
de loi de finances est un projet melun
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
prévoit 0% d'augmentation c'est la
première fois depuis 21 ans
madame la sénatrice d'augmentation la
dépense publique permettez-moi et xange
vous n'y voyez aucune espèce de mépris
de ma part de vous appeler dans le débat
parlementaire à la même cohérence
j'ai suivi avec olivier dussopt pts mais
on regarde bien les heures de présence
j'ai fait les deux tiers jusqu'à présent
de débats parlementaires en commission
et dans cet hémicycle
j'ai suivi madame la sénatrice vos
propositions qu'a proposé la majorité
sénatoriale moins d'impôts non vous avez
proposé de taxer les complémentaires -
aussi - dépenses subissent non vous avez
proposé d'augmenter de 600 millions
d'euros
de 600 millions d'euros les questions
autour de la famille donc madame la
sénatrice je suis d'accord serait
incohérent ensemble merci